[Music]
in John Tucker Must Die news kotatsu
submitted by the alotta man oh my god
if they put mayo and butter and cheese
on a cockroach on my eat it mmm why I am
hostile regime Chicago's are nasty and
tangy but if you fry right and you put
mayo butter cheese
I mean finally anyone sorry pretty good
I like how Mexican food they find the
best way to make the healthiest thing
super unhealthy yeah walk yet have you
ever had Mexican fruits it's like let me
just add extra sugar extra cream extra
fun a lot of extra sodium sodium odium
yellow so alright this guy but six dates
in one night and of course all the ones
on that oh it's a bad look Herman has
six dates on one night was he trying to
get like a huge orgy we're gonna forget
you because he said of multiple date
Sunday night there on purpose and you
wanted me so here we go wait you got a
lot of money money yeah taking [ __ ]
out true yeah let's are all at the part
I don't feel like double depart date
yeah six picnic blankets yes it keeps
running from one to the other and then
that's what he found out they saw him
talking between kissing what yeah so
this woman named Lisette she tweets her
story yes I love when they put their
drama on [ __ ] blast mm-hmm so here's
the beginning she said spread alert so I
go on what I think might be a date with
a guy my friend set me up on my birthday
parenthesis yes it's a bit hazy we meet
up at a bar my friend works at she said
friend proceeds to text me telling me
this guy sucks and I should run I show
up and he sucks but I figured okay
because I mean this guy sucks maybe or
something like she's a bartender the
friends instead of with the friend
notion sure you know who this person
exactly I got two nuns reading this I've
never said anyone suck though like what
does that mean
like no my friends are terribly it could
be their friend and go yeah you're
probably might have not established like
word or term for what would you do for
something like to discuss sucks dick but
there needs to be something like what
are you sucking you know any specific
like like Ryan you mean or lines lazy
hmm I tell you a guy's folks would you
know what I mean yeah yeah what does
that mean like wouldn't it means like
don't waste your time like don't buy
another one
I could only see on TV at TV sucks okay
don't get don't get that one but that's
exactly what started shopping for people
oh my god men are not objects
Oh remember you rated like you sucks or
he's bad or good but men is amazing to
women no just don't I don't get it like
I got my dog [ __ ] us up there's nothing
you have to get it's just it's just like
straight to the point doesn't move on
like don't waste your time yucky
poisonous dude um she says I show up and
he sucks but I figured I'll stay because
my friends are working at the BART so 45
minutes and his next date shows up
because he doubled books himself and he
decides he's going to friend on me to
get out of the situation I decided both
wave-around
in order to help the girl feel less
awkward and so he exits for a moment and
then I tell her what's up we'll call
this girl Katie Katie gets in on my
quest to make this guy feel like the
[ __ ] boy he clearly is and we chat for
thirty minutes then the third girl shows
yeah we'll call her Riley the guy leaves
again and Riley
Katie and I team up and decide to JT
must die vicious sick so John Tucker
Must Die as a movie where's your girls
at the same time they all find out and
they all conspire against all the two
girls and I have now gotten both
bartenders and the bouncer in on this
and we're taking this guy for all he's
worth over here
he's now explaining why he broke up with
his ex and Riley asked if he also met
her on a group date don't worry we
already asked if there's going to be a
rose ceremony
the two girls and I decide to be best
friends left together to go good drink
and dinner at another bar and let's
homeboy with the bill the end no our
guys not over
Oh more to this yeah I guess only at
four huh
yeah we're only out for the bartender
just text texted us to tell us homeboy
is on another date so I send my friend
over to retrieve his 8:00 p.m. date he's
so popular I'm feeling joopa Dino wow
you even get six women to accept just
swipe right oh that's that's not easy
you chose so I'm feeling his dates and
making them my friends and I'm so here
for it and then she put the little
dresses and we just become best friends
from Step Brothers and then she's like
we're now all hanging out at another bar
together and then she posts a picture
the three of them Oh was she she is this
one so she so this guy is just kind of
just I don't like you
next one really lies you said he just
keeps bringing them into the same bar
yeah
6p dating yeah he speed dating he for
himself not telling anybody pretty
efficient and he's the one dismissing
the girls and he's bringing new ones in
because he's like yeah he had already
booked them all like 40 minutes apart or
45 minutes apart Wow continue guys a
genius
let's eat this guy probably look good or
something because all of these women
accepted to come chill with them so she
says you guys girl numbers five just
showed up before going to meet him
because my friends intercepted her and
told her not to waste your time my
friend is now arguing with said guy and
his current date number four about why
she shouldn't waste your time and just
leave mrs. steal your girl over here and
then they added another girl to the
group just gonna yeah Kings are all
hanging out at the bar so they're just
there to cock-block now yeah we knew
it's like he doesn't really have a table
um he's the kind of guy that likes the
shotgun that means to shoot into a big
crowd of birds and hopefully you catch
some
this was a crowd of birds so she
continues y'all will call her Ali Ali
hasn't actually met him yet and is now
baiting him that she's still on her way
but we've already stolen her weave
button girl number four we'll call her
Claire to come over once she finishes
her date so she can debrief with us how
did it go mind Elron who's going before
they even get there yeah I have no clue
but then she continues girl number five
Ali has headed over with her new BFF
which I mean I don't know that gay best
friend mmm
so the answers I he told date number
five that she was already cut and to say
hi to me at the bar wench when she
invited him to drink with us it's all
she was pretty much live tweeting this
entire thing you guys haven't caught on
my number yeah went outside to make a
call and ran into him leaving number
five he then tells me I'm the only one
he wants to get to know still but that I
should tell him if she should just [ __ ]
off
I tell him there's a difference between
being efficient and being an [ __ ] and
he goes into well I'm a project manager
I manage my time efficiently and I say
there's no way to know someone in 40
minutes if you have five dates lined up
you told him Wow you didn't seem like
that and resigned himself to the fact
that I wanted to walk away laughing at
him he tried to say he was looking for
love and his future wife these weren't
dates they were apparently predate
conversations and then she's just like
ends up saying that she doesn't use any
app but this is wild you win some you
lose some but hopefully you make three
new best friends in the process cheers
and I should post another photo with
them and then she continues we went back
and he's with number six he finally
realized he wasn't winning and just
walked out number six and her mom and
her aunt are now our best friends
Fumi cares I want to see what this kind
of looks like no we're not story it was
told kind of weird to my opinion but
apparently that's all these girls do
like how do you know who those she had a
connect to her bartender so maybe the
bartender really
now that doesn't make any sense could
she be inciting him I don't know I don't
know but this story was submitted by you
guys so now and the bartender
hooked her up no the bartender was the
friend oh yeah hooked her up with the
guys beginning jo-ann issues end of
college that was saying that some of the
girls that she ended up making friends
with that they met him on different
dating apps but that was her like she
actually just met him in real life like
I'm not on any dating app I actually met
this dude in real life we dick yeah
apparently they was Justin anybody with
that name man Bruce [ __ ] pricks we
know it doesn't no one completely
opposite
oh yeah he's cool I like you but that
just goes to show man the way that the
dating world works for guys is like
there's usually like five guys out of a
hundred that gets all the girls
and then like everybody else just has
the hardest time trying to get with one
yeah it's true that's how it works maybe
they're too thirsty what do you
recommend or like what do you think is a
better approach like go for a ton or
just wear your hands on what you want do
you want a long-term relationship do you
want to have some fun and experience all
kinds of different minds and boobies
what do you want to do like do you want
to have physical fun that is like
short-term and you know what do you want
it depends right I think the fun with
gaining like a bunch of different people
and stuff but maybe not all in the same
day okay night holy [ __ ] and it depends
on what is the rules of dating for you
yeah like is dating just I like to get
to know you kind of emotionally and like
working toward something or I was just
going out having fun experiencing each
other and maybe some sex on the way like
people by the way like people idea of
dating is really different right there's
no like real set rules yeah but that's
kind of [ __ ] up though like to not
give someone the appropriate amount of
time or choice it's like it was on his
time his like planned and like you just
so happened to be the object of his
desire for those 40 minutes
that's [ __ ] up don't know what
projects with sky mesh you know I don't
know what field is you think is that
really good though if you think about it
I'd probably hire him because he knows
what he's doing victims of inner people
skills or whatever you focus on projects
like the old people though I know this
really sucks never mind the easy works
at a cracker factory my cracker Rogers
Alan it's time you to be used
efficiently for I don't know I'm just
taking somewhere that has an assembly
line and you just got to move around
people all right hammer Stamper come
over here all right [ __ ] salt shaker
go get over there dough maker come over
here all right we have 30 minutes for
the white bread crackers than the
whole-wheat crackers to come in and
invest in your treasure fish damn
saltine crackers
good job title names oh yeah I like it
this way I was going to nobody knows
what that word really is rubber gloves
yes goggles on anything why is he using
an old holiday that's mine why did you
just use the [ __ ] machine that
already has it I see a light sprinkle
pepper you know like a small big I like
this it's that personal finish that
person went first you take pride in
being a handmade cracker factory you're
you're okay the Pepperidge Farm this
isn't [ __ ] Nabisco signing off my
would be Nabisco my would have a
pre-measured machine that doesn't need
this [ __ ] guys that's not germane
okay finally give the garbage out Ryan
what [ __ ] was cracker factory which
you want his or mine
mine has a pre yeah I've heard the
different kinds of cracker that he's
made we've got a diverse selection
cracker oh wow you're gonna choose your
bottle over me why are you because she's
going to replace you with machine oh
it's true I take pride in being made in
America
she's an operator for those machines
operators actually you'll find a AI that
will replace all of it until that maybe
I should invest in a different jumps to
the cracker manufacturers your boss
that's what people need practice hey
guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]
you
[Music]